يعني على ما يبدو فان التصعيد الان
المرتقب قد بدا هذه النقطه البدايه يعني
يبدو انه الساعات الماضيه كانت ساعات
استعداد ولم يكن
باي شيء بسبب اي شيء اخر كما ذكرت في
بدايه حديثك
نعم البيان الذي يعني تم توزيعه على وسائل
الاعلام قبل ساعات قليله يؤكد ذلك
الان مره اخرى وكما اعتدنا بالامس وقبل
الامس هذه المضادات بدات تشتغل وتطلق
طلقاتها
على ما يبدو فان تبادل النيران سيزداد
بكثافه مع بدايه
يعني ظهور ملامح
يعني الصباح مع
اتضاح الرؤيه
تتضح الاهداف اكثر فاكثر وتزداد الكثافه
الايرانيه وهنا يزداد شده التحذير من
ضروره عدم الخروج او الاقتراب من النوافذ
او الجدر القريبه المطله على الشوارع او
يعني
الاتجاهات التي قد تاتي منها
الاصابات هناك صور انتشرت لي بعض المباني
التي كانت قد تعرضت لي يعني
هذه القذائف وقد تدمرت يعني هو احدثت
فتحات كبيره في هذه الجزر وهناك بالفعل
الكثير من الضحايا ذهبوا يعني نتيجه
اصابات حتى داخل منازلهم نعم حوالي 200
قتيل حتى الان بالمناسبه في يعني احصائيه
ليست نهائيه وحوالي الالف جريح ستتضح
الارقام اكثر فاكثر
عن 1800 مصاب وكذلك 185 قتيل
نعم كان ذلك في توقيت مبكر من اليوم مع
تقدم الساعات واستمرار العمليات وسقوط هذه
القذايف والدانات على المنازل فان الاعداد
قد تكون اكبر من ذلك يعني بكثير وهذا طبعا
ليس فقط في في الخرطوم هذا في الخرطوم في
غيره من المواقع الاخرى ايضا هناك
اشتباكات في اجابه في القاعده العسكريه في
مروي او في محيط هذه القاعده ايضا كان
هناك حديث عن احتمال
تسلل يعني هذه العناصر التي خرجت من
القاعده هناك الى داخل الاحياء في مدينه
مرر بمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات